okay so welcome back to the uh last
session of the morning and so we're
super happy to have uh tamera bashar
joining us to uh tell us about
multi-agent rl in the uh high population
regime so i'll uh i'll let you take it
away okay thanks
thanks it's great to be here it's a
wonderful workshop and i'm enjoying it
i think this is the
only
presentation that deals with an infinite
number of agents in the program if i'm
not mistaken so so i have to give you a
little bit of a background i don't know
what the
background of the of the audience
is uh on the mean field approach to
games
dynamic games but i should first
say that this is based on a
recent work with
a student of mine
anik
and and the postdoc eric kneeling
and but but the the work originated in
the
uh
uh
back in uh
2020
uh when kai ching was also at illinois
so so we this is the
single population version of that it's
it was a preliminary work which then
led to this uh
paper that i'm going to talk about to
the extent possible but as i said i want
to give first a high level introduction
to mean field games so that
will be on board as the what the
framework is
and
so the the outline is as i said i'll
give a high level
introduction to stochastic dynamic games
and then take them out to mean field
games which is a
has
been
of interest to a broader community
actually
in the last 15 years or so
and
and then i will
go focus on linear quadratic
mean field games because you can obtain
explicit solutions in that context and
then move from there to multi population
linear quadratic beam field games
and and first
the first part of the talk is going to
be model based and
and the the mean field equilibrium
computation simplifies
the uh
both the existence and uniqueness of
equilibria and also provides with some
epsilon mesh
guarantees if it's used in the finite
population
regime
and then i'll
move in the second part to as time
allows to
reinforcement learning and
and the zero order stochastic
optimization
uh talk about some finite sample
guarantees uh all for the
multi-population case and then
some uh numerical results and and then
conclude
so so game theory and and this is all uh
well known uh to this community is that
provides the the right
modeling framework as well as the
computational framework that captures
interactions among multiple
agents and they could be physical
economic social and even biological
and these agents have misaligned
objectives and and you have you can have
zero some
games but the zero sum doesn't
necessarily mean that you have only two
players you can have zero sum between
two teams for example
and uh and also non-zero sum which has
been discussed extensively so far at
this workshop
and
going uh to dynamic game theory then we
have a much richer
framework there
and and that captures the evolution of
these interactions over time and
but in that case the uh information
structure plays an important role who
knows what and and when
and and the memory restrictions play an
important role uh how deep into the past
two agents recall
and and how much of this is common
information to the agents
and then the resource constraints uh
play an important role and the
allocation of resources over time and
how they are utilized
and and also the trade-offs between
short-term and long-term goals and that
could be
captured through the uh
cost function so these all play
important roles
and and there are multiple solutions uh
concepts
for dynamic games as well as for static
games we can have nash and stack of work
and for dynamic games the mark of
perfect equilibrium and these are all
tailored to the scenario at hand
and the roles of different players in
this decision-making process whether
it's symmetric hierarchical whether one
player dominates the decision-making
process or not
now when we go to an infinite population
uh
regime
then the interactions among players take
a different meaning and and and that
leads to mean field games as i'm going
to
discuss
in somewhat more detail
shortly
and and the associated solution concept
in that case is is meme field equilibria
coming back to uh uh
finite uh
uh
population games
uh we have if the uh
uh
if if the players have
closed loop perfect state measurements
they measure the state the entire state
not on the local state
uh
and then there is an almost complete
theory for this whether you have linear
quadratic games or or non-linear games
with nonlinear
dynamics as well as under open loop
information then that essentially
converts the game to a static one
and
also uh
for the stackelberg equilibrium
uh in that case the the players have
asymmetric roles so there is a leader or
there could be multiple leaders but
let's talk about the case when there is
a single leader and and then several
followers and so if the leader has open
loop information in other words does not
observe
the actions of the other players or the
state then this is a relatively easier
problem and there is an almost complete
[Music]
theory on that i'm talking about model
based or model based
approaches but when the leader has
closely perfect state information
observes the state and and maybe also
the actions of the other players then
the monitoring is possible on the part
of the leader
and it's it's very challenging uh to
obtain the stackelberg equilibrium
through a direct approach but an
indirect approach which has connections
to mechanism design is feasible now if
you have other types of dynamic
information
like local state for example think of
again a game dynamic game where each
player has access only
to
its own state and not his access to the
states of other agents or you have
decentralized measurements or
measurement you you want to use
measurement feedback static measurement
feedback then these are extremely
challenging problems and and the reason
is
generally and they lead to infinite
dimensional
policies even if nash equilibrium exists
and is unique and even in linear
quadratic
nonzero some games
the it is
if you have local state information then
there isn't a theory complete theory for
that
now the reason for this the reason for
this challenge and for this difficulty
is the strategic interaction among the
players and
each player has to if
if let's even consider the case of a
two-player game where the players have
different information
and
and the information one player has on
the environment
is maybe more reliable than the
information the other player has on the
environment and so therefore the
the one who has less information has to
infer or second guess the information
available to the other player or players
and
and and and that will be useful in
uh
to her in improving her performance
so if all players are doing this second
guessing then this leads to an infinite
recursion
and an asymptotically
learning process
comes in
and and learning development information
through direct measurement of others
actions and through their impact so this
is an extremely difficult problem
and the way out
is to this is the mean field approach if
you have a large number of players
because if you have a large number of
players then what a single agent does
provided that you have the right
structure what a single player does or
deviates
from
an equilibrium does not affect
the
the aggregate quantity
which couples the the players
and so so in other words in a in an
infinite population or in a very large
population what one player does is not
that significant but what they do in
aggregate is is important
so uh
so
suppose that so it has to be a
a certain
specific structure
the the underlying game has to have and
suppose that
we have the
evolution of the state of each agent in
an employer game
it depends on all other agent states not
individually but through an aggregate
term
and and and this could be
you could have an underlying network and
an agent's uh
state could depend on the states of
other agents in the neighborhood but as
in through an aggregate term and it has
to to be a large number of agents in
that neighborhood
so there could be a similar dependence
coming into the cost function of the of
the agent so so what you do is is
if there is this uh
aggregate quantity let me call it x n so
this is the state the average state and
n stands for the number of players
and where n is large so you can treat
this
in the
uh
while obtaining the solution to the game
and i'm talking about nash equilibrium
now
is a fixed stochastic process and this
is known as the mean field term you
don't know what it is
but you can take it as a as a given
and
and and this is the mass behavior of the
of all the players or of the remaining
players whether you include that
specific player in that population or
not doesn't make any difference
and and this is uh
stochastic processes and
is exogenous to any particular agent
and it's not affected by individual
agents actions so so that's very
important
then what happens is that
so this in a sense
the coupling is through the mean field
term so therefore what each agent
each agent knows that he's not going to
affect the mean field terms so that's
why it's an exogenous process so each
agent faces a stochastic control problem
or a stochastic dynamic optimization
problem
and which has to be solved for each fn
for each mass behavior for each
characterization
and and this leads to in the continuous
time and making glass of type of state
equation
so so you
solve this stochastic control problem
and obtain the uh the the control
optimal control of an agent is a
function of that mass behavior of the
mean field
and then you generate the state process
under these optimal controls
and and this leads to a focal plant
called modular forward equation again in
continuous time
and then you require
consistency with the mean field
and
which you had taken as a as a variable
into the is an exogenous process
and as n goes to infinity this entails
solving a fixed point equation and one
can prove existence under certain
conditions existence and uniqueness of
the solution to that fixed point
equation and so therefore existence of a
mean field and so together with the
optimal control policies this leads to
a mean field equilibrium
then what one does and and just to close
the loop if we are really interested in
the nash equilibrium solution of a fine
hyper has
also a finite population problem which
we cannot solve because of the
underlying information structures note
that the stochastic control problem can
always be solved under whatever the
information structure you have
particularly if you have local
information local state information or
even even
imperfect information where you can you
can uh have a control on the on the
belief state evolution of the beliefs of
that individual
so so but we want to come back to the
finite population
game
and and the question is if you use the
solution that you obtain
from this this mean field equilibrium
and the control associated with that
uh
in in a finite population game do i
obtain an a
an approximate nash equilibrium does
this lead to it
and indeed one can show that this leads
to an approximate nash equilibrium in
general the epsilon is like the error
is like 1 over square root of n
and so so this is a way of obtaining the
an approximate nash equilibrium for a
game
which you cannot otherwise solve or
which you cannot otherwise even go for
an epsilon nash equilibrium unless you
take this route
and of course it's it's uh
epsilon as i indicated is connected to
the to the number of players
so this research was initiated by the
mayfield approach by lesbian and and
lyons from france uh which appeared in
the japan journal of math in 2007 and
and almost in parallel but in a
different framework the uh
peter kane's in canada and together with
two of his colleagues they
uh published a paper in the transaction
from automatic control
and now you can you can bring in with
sensitivity formulation which is this
sensitivity means that agents may have
different sort of ways of looking into
their risks
and and you can have a sensitive or risk
risk averse or
or
we're seeking behavior on the part of
the agents and and so we we have
obtained strong results in that context
for this sense the mean field games and
this was in the transactions on
automatic control in 2014
and and and also the stackelberg
equilibrium in other words when you have
one uh leader
uh and then several minor players and
the minor players are playing
uh nash and then the uh
the single player the the major player
is playing a leadership role
the game so so that can one can again
show epsilon optimalities in these
contexts
and and for general discrete time markov
decision processes in the most general
case with also imperfect measurements
uh we have recent results which uh
with uh my colleague
waginski and and the postdoc we had at
the time naji salvi and which appeared
in the mathematics of operations
research 2019 and 20 as well as in the
same journal and control different
versions with risk sensitivity and and
with imperfect measurements as well as
with perfect measurements
so
uh
the
input the sort of benefit of taking this
route is that the mean field equilibrium
based approximate nash equilibrium is
scalable
definitely
and the computation of this mean field
nash equilibrium requires solution of a
fixed point equation and and and which
of course requires full modeling
knowledge
now one way around this
and this will play a role actually in
the
in the reinforcement learning approach
that i'll be discussing shortly
is uh to interact with the central
coordinator of simulator
so so the the the simulator collects
state values of the agents or the
and then computes the mean field so the
mean field is computation is done at
by this central coordinator and then
broadcast this because this is an
aggregate quantity that others are
interested in and which is input into
their stochastic control problems
uh and and then the agents obtain the
stochastic
their policies based on that approximate
mean field
and
and and and then
uh transmit those to again the central
coordinator the central coordinator
updates
and so on and then one can show that
this actually
converges under under some conditions
now this is uh all i have discussed is
maybe you may think that there is all
agents are homogeneous and and there is
a
sort of a single population but it can
be extended to finite a number of
different populations of agents where
the agents populations are connected
over a network
and so you can if as long as you have a
finite number l of different populations
of agents a representative agent from
each population or
all agents from a particular population
sends inputs to the central coordinator
and then the central coordinator now
computes l different mean fields and
then transmits that to the uh
to the players
and
so now the question is what if the
agents do not know their own models
and because this
generally the fixed point of course
computation without essential
coordinator requires full modeling
knowledge on the part of the agents and
when you have a central coordinator of
course there then you have a
the agent should be able to solve their
stochastic control problems uh
explicitly
and and but if they don't have full
model
of their own models then this is not
possible then this brings in the
reinforcement learning to this context
so so this talk after this fairly long
introduction
will address in the remaining part
within the linear quadratic consensus
formation setting
uh this uh
reinforcement learning a problem for
multi-populations
we have developed a learning algorithm
on the field for mean field games based
on zero order stochastic optimization
techniques
and then
we can we have demonstrated that the
multi-agent reinforcement learning in
large heterogeneous populations can be
effectively addressed within the
framework of of mean field games so so
here's the specific uh
sort of game
and and this is a consensus game uh
which is uh
very well this is the case of a
when there is a single population so i
just want to motivate this and then
we'll extend it to multiple populations
so you have a
each agent and
so in that single
population has a linear dynamics and u
is the u is the control and then w is
the noise this is the zero mean gaussian
noise each agent has only local
information in other words uh knows what
happened in the past as far as its own
control uh goes
and then and then has the history of the
states of of uh that agent's local
dynamics so which is z and t
and
and the agents have
the only coupling between the agents in
this formulation
is through the cost function
and the cost function as you can see has
the uh and this is a consensus problem
so uh
there is the the the standard sort of a
quadratic cause as as it appears in the
regulator problem so if i didn't have
this then this would be an independent
optimization problem for each agent but
each agent wants to get as close to the
average of the states its state to get
close to the average of the states of
other ages okay so so this is this is
what uh where the coupling comes from so
this is the regulation uh term what i
have it in green and then this is the
consensus term and and the problems of
this type arise in in many in flocking
problems and
and
formation problems with multiple
aircraft and so on
and and also in in
opinion dynamics where agents want to
get close to each other's uh
opinions
if that if that works in a single
village
so uh so the the matrices there are all
non-negative definite or positive
definite and then the approximate nash
equilibrium
is defined in this way
and and note that this problem with
local state information for the agents
cannot be solved
using any direct approach there is no
theory which will tell us
what the
optimal solution is like if n is
uh larger than or equal to two okay
and
so the so the mean field uh approach uh
to this is uh to have the the mean field
to replace this uh
average term with z bar of t so this is
the mean field term and we don't know
this
what this term is at this point and to
solve this but this
decouples the agent's
optimization problem and this is a time
average
and
and
you solve a stochastic control problem
where in this case the agent's control
is going to depend
only on the state on its own state not
on the states of the other agents as
well as on the mean field term and this
is a sort of a tracking problem as you
can see
so this is again regulation and this is
the consensus
and
so so what one does is as i indicated
earlier
for each
mean field
you solve the stochastic
optimal control problem for each agent
in this case the agents are
indistinguishable there is a single
population so therefore there is a
generic agent if you obtain the solution
for that generic agent then then then
you have the optimal controls for all
other agents in terms of their local
states
and and then you look for consistency
the the
uh under that control
of that generic agent the average and
note that the controls are the same
across all agents the average satisfies
and an equation of the stuff okay
and
and so what we are looking for is a
fixed point
okay so so you want to make sure that
that the z bar here that has been used
is consistent with the z-bar that you
obtained
through here
and
so
this existence and uniqueness of the
mean field
equilibrium is guaranteed under some
standard assumptions and and one can
also show that the mean field
equilibrium is also nash
uh for the an agent game and as i
indicated earlier for this
uh problem one can vigorously
show that
actually the the error
uh it's an epsilon nash equilibrium in
an an agent uh problem and the error is
in the order of one over square root of
n
so
how can we extend this to multi
populations
now the with multi populations uh let's
say that you have l
uh
a
different populations l is a finite
number of course
and
the dynamics
for an agent for a
typical agent a generic agent in the
health
population
said
is generated by a linear equation of
this type note that the a and b
could depend on the population itself as
well as the
properties of the noise okay each agent
again has only local information and
agents uh have coupled functions cost
functions
and and the scope link is such that
again you have the regulation term here
and
and you have
as in the
single population case this is the
intra-population consensus that is uh
the agent in the elf population a
generic agent wants to be as close as
possible to the average
within that population
and also uh there is this this is this
is what connects
the different populations and and data
in this case is a bias term
so so the uh the agent in the elf
population
wants to be at some distance
from the agents
in the neighboring populations and here
the script l sub l is the set of
immediate neighbors of that population
okay so so so you want i mean this is
applications in in different different
sort of
uh
has different paradigms
where
you want you want in opinion dynamics
for example you are clustering with
those who are carrying a similar
opinions with you but you want to stay
away from those who are who do not share
the same opinions with you and that's
beta uh characterizes that distance
which is a which is a positive quantity
and you are only
connecting
uh with the neighbors so there is an
underlying underlying
topology graph topology but but but
everything is you have you have
connectedness in this case
so so you can introduce the the notion
of an epsilon nash equilibrium for the
finite
game again in the in the usual way
and
and and and what you do now is that you
have
different populations and so therefore
each one will have a separate will have
a different
mean field so there are l different mean
fields
and and then and uh and so this is the
state equation for that uh player
uh for the l player for the generic
player in the in the elf population so i
denote it this way
and uh and and then let's let's call the
z bar as the collection of these the one
bar through zl bar so each one is the
mean field of the respective
corresponding population
and
and and so therefore the uh
what you have is again the regulation uh
term inter-population consensus as well
as the entire population concessions
okay so so the uh
a
existence of a mean field
equilibrium for this multi-population
case
essentially what we are looking for is
still a fixed point
and but in this case we are looking for
a fixed point for the
l population game so therefore the z bar
has its components each one is a mean
field for the
corresponding uh
uh for the for the health uh
uh population itself so so we are again
looking for for a
a fixed point and the question is is
whether that can be
uh solved now one thing one can show the
existence
and the uniqueness of the mean field
equilibrium in this multi-population
case we have to make some assumptions
because we're dealing with an infinite
horizon problem time average
these are the standard assumptions that
the al for each population the a b
matrices are controllable and a q
make this our observable so that the
underlying stochastic control problem
has a well-defined unique solution
for each for each mean field
and
so therefore the the the control turns
out to be
linear
and and it is linear in the uh
[Music]
in the state of the so for a typical
uh generic player in the elf population
it's uh it's linear in the state of the
elf
uh
population or or the the that
agents uh health agents or the or the
typical agents in the health
population the state of that age
it's a linear function of the mean field
and and it's also uh there's a
a bias term here and and which is due to
that beta where you want separation
between the between different population
between the main fields and then we can
also show that
the mean field
is
z bar star which is the which is the
concatenated mean fields of the ldl
populations satisfies a a linear
equation evolution
and
and so this f star is the matrix to be
determined and c star is a biased term
if beta were zero then the c star would
not be there and this would not be there
also so the only unknowns would be these
two
and and f star so the so the
reinforcement learning
algorithm in this case if you don't know
the
parameters of the game but you know that
you have a linear structure
for the model itself but the solution is
linear that is
no loss of generality
and
so
so what we're looking for is essentially
learning about these uh matrices
and vectors okay
uh l2 is a is a vector and c star also
is a is a vector
so so these are the linear terms and
this one is an off sector
and uh
so uh the proof of this result the mean
uh
the the multi-population case it's the
existence and uniqueness and the
affineness
is is uh proving using probabilistic
approach from carmona and de la route
and uh and the equilibrium controller
actually is a solution to a linear
quadratic
affine tracking problem so it's exactly
and one can use stochastic maximum
principle for that
so the uh the implications of this
result is that at equilibrium the mean
field has a deterministic effing
dynamics
which
we can be computed
so that it's deterministic because of
the linear structure the average of all
the uh
the states uh satisfies a deterministic
equation and so that requires an offline
computation so if you knew uh what all
those parameters were of what the
underlying sort of model was
then you can compute it a fixed point
and the and the controller is causal
that's the important thing normally when
you solve and a tracking problem you
don't obtain a causal controller in the
mean field but we can show that you can
turn things around and obtain a causal
controller
the the uh
the solution the the
the uh additional terms uh
the offset terms are actually normally
uh they satisfy a backwards equation
because of dynamic programming but you
can show that there's a forward equation
which characterizes them
as well
and and this the the fact that the
controller is causing allows for
uh reinforcement learning but in a
non-stationary setting
that's not a stationary reinforcement
learning problem
and
so so the question is what happens in
the multi-population case
when i use
for each player uh what uh
the this analysis kicks out
for the for the infinite population case
how much do i lose
and
so what is the
had
mentioned earlier that in the single
population case the error
is in the order of 1 over square root of
n
in the case of multiple populations the
error
is in the order of the minimum
of the
uh number of agents so so different
population for this is this is for the
elf
uh
population the a generic agent in the
earth population or the nth agent in the
l population so you look at the
neighbors
of that population
and the immediate neighbors
and you look at the number of players in
each neighborhood
the minimum number of that
is what replaces the n in the case of a
single population okay so it's one over
so so you cannot afford
to have some of the populations having
very low numbers and this includes the
the
the population of the elf population as
well counted in this okay so so this is
the this is the error
that you make that each agent makes
terms of nash equilibrium if it uses the
solution that comes out of the mean
field equilibrium okay
and
and so this uh proof relies on
quantifying the difference between
equilibrium mean field and the empirical
mean field
and
the steady state distribution of the
difference depends on on
the number of agents in the health group
and and and that
difference goes to zero as the number of
agents goes to infinite okay
so this is the implications i already
discussed
so so what do we do
for the reinforcement learning i i have
little time left but
if anybody is interested in that paper
which which has the full details of the
proofs and
and the results uh please send me an
email and and i can send you
uh the paper itself
so uh
so most of the the uh so the challenge
here was that
most of the algorithms for linear
quadratic mean field games rl algorithms
deal with stationary equilibria and the
single population setting so we had to
extend it to non-stationary
systems as well as the
multi-population
cases
and each agent in each population is
unaware of its dynamics and cost
functions so that's has to be learned
and and each agent has access to only a
noisy estimate of the controller cost
and
and and we use
zero order stochastic optimizations
which i'm going to refer to as zso
based uh reinforcement learning which
performs stochastic gradient descent and
and computes smooth gradient using noise
estimates of the
cost take only one one sample
so so what uh uh
to bring it into the reinforcement uh
learning framework what we have to do is
we have to lump everything together so
remember we had a
a state equation
for each agent
and
and
and we also
in the in the elf population and we also
have the the mean field which is the the
the l different mean fields which i have
lumped them as as z bar t so z bar uh
satisfies this linear equation and we
know what what zlt satisfies so you can
lump them together concatenate them and
then write it in terms of
x x is the new state now
in this form where b and and and a bar
have some specific structures and note
that we don't know what a l is and we
don't know what b f is
and we don't know what b sub l is and we
don't know what c is okay
and
so therefore the
optimization problem faced
by a generic agent in the elf population
is uh can be written in this form
okay
and uh
so therefore this is a
drifted linear quadratic regulator
problem
and and and which brings it to the
framework of of application of
reinforcement learning
so so we are looking we know that the
solution is linear
so we are
uh looking for a solution in this space
that is the
control is a linear function of x as
well as this bias term
now under this controller so we want to
find out what k is and kl is learn these
once you substitute this these into this
cost function one uh
thing that comes out is that
there is an additive decomposition the
first part
depends on kl1
and the and the second part depends on
kl1k l2 as well as the z bar and this
one also depends on z bar
but if the control offset and the
dynamics offset are zero then this term
drops out and then
you end up with this term as well so so
this suggests
a sort of an inner loop out of loop
learning process
and and you first learn about
about kl1
and then you learn about kl2
and the and the offset terms okay
and uh
so for linear they can be
learned in a in a decoupled way
and uh
let me see
so so so here is the the sort of a
general approach but proving that it
works and it converges and so on sample
uh
point analysis and and is
is quite involved
uh
so so in both parts in estimating both
parts both the linear as well as the
hospital the offset terms each agent
uses
a zero order stochastic optimization the
centralized simulator computes the mean
field under the set of controllers so
there is
interaction with the with the
centralized which will compute the mean
field and and sends it back to the to
the agent uh
a
so the the first part so the algorithm
consists of two parts the first part
deals with the linear terms in the
controllers
and the end the mean fields
and then by keeping the offset terms
zero so as though there is no coupling
the second part deals with the offset
terms in the controller and mean fields
which brings in the in the coupling
okay so so this is what the centralized
simulator
uh
uh
and
and which leads to uh
uh
collects
the uh controllers from the uh from the
the individual local states and and we
we add a
a noise here sorry
you know it's because this is collected
from a single representative agent in
the in the health population so this is
the simulation
error noise
and
so the linear mean field is is uh
is this one that
this
in the first part of this this algorithm
the central
uh
simulator sense and in the second part
of the algorithm the controller turns
out to be fine and that's what's sent to
the uh to the center of simulate
and uh so i i don't have time to go into
the details of this zso based uh rl
algorithm but it it's uh you first
estimate the linear terms the zso
updates the linear controller
and the simulator updates the linear
mean field and then you
move to estimating the offset terms
and
and zso updates the control offset and
the simulator updates the mean field
offset
okay
and and and this is uh sort of the
standard uh cso algorithm and uh
and and which is
uh based on uh
computing a smooth gradient uh
given the given the samples
and
so uh so these the parameters of the zso
there there is the smoothing radius r
there is the number of perturbations is
k that's the minimum batch size
the learning rate is is eta
and the number of iterations that you do
is is r and if you decrease the the
perturbation norm
uh
then uh then that decreases the bias but
increases the variance
in the in the gradient computation
the variance is reduced by increasing k
uh
the minute batch size
and the learning rate eta of course uh
brings a trade-off between stability and
and speed
and
and and the higher r is the better
convergence of cso that you have it's
linear
so so
we have the the paper has uh
sort of exact expressions for all these
r1 r2 and so on
so that you have given an an epsilon
one
uh you have uh
uh
in the in the first part of the
algorithm
you can get uh
within epsilon one over two
of the uh
of the gain of the controller this is
the the linear part of the controller
there is a is a similar uh uh result for
the second part
uh the offset term
and
and and again if you uh
have uh
and
for any epsilon 2 over 2 you can obtain
these
different values of these different
parameters so that the difference is
less than or equal to epsilon 2 so you
can you can approximately to any degree
of approximation
and and this is of course happens with
some probability at least 1 minus delta
2
so you can reach the the optimum
solution
and and and there are finite sample
guarantees for zso as well for the
offset term and and uh
and then
you bring the two together
uh the two parts of the algorithm the
outlook outer loop and the inner loop
and then
prove finite sample guarantees for the
for this combined
system
and
let me let me just
go to
i'm almost i'm over time so so we have
simulated uh this algorithm for three
populations
and the and these uh three populations
are one of them is the is the chain
network
and and chain network uh of course would
mean that
there is one uh
population in the middle who is
connected to two different populations
but then those two on the outs side of
the chain
on the outer side of the chain they
don't have direct interaction between
themselves and the ring network is is
one where you have everybody
all the populations are connected to
each other
we have the scalar state and action
spaces
and and these plus show the
estimation error and the standard
deviation of the mean field equilibrium
and you can see that this is uh
this is 0.05 and this is almost zero so
there is a
a drop immediate drop
in the in the error
and the standard deviation also is
dropping quite
rapidly initially and then constant
decline
and
and this one is is is a bit i
show similar behavior
but but the variance here the standard
deviation is a little bit higher this is
slower
than than this one this is the ring
network so this is everybody is
connected to everyone so if you have a
network where you do not have
uh
dense connections then then things will
be
will converge faster
and
so
so what we have uh
i have talked about is multi-agent rl
from a mean field game perspective
uh with heterogeneous agents moved in in
populations different populations
established existence and the
uniqueness and affine structure for the
mean field equilibrium
and
also establishing epsilon nash
guarantees
and the affine structure which is no
loss of generality
provided that you stay with the linear
dynamics and quadratic
cost function but beyond that you don't
have to know the
specifics the parameters in the dynamics
so this leads to a two-part area
algorithm to estimate the new field
equilibrium and we have used
zero the stochastic optimization
techniques finite sample convergence
guarantees for the algorithm and then
the the last slide i had was on a three
population setting and this opens the
door for extensions in different
directions and
[Music]
and
robust robustness issues to risk
sensitivity for example what happens if
the agents are not are not neutral but
we're sensitive in different populations
different populations may have different
behavioral assumptions and this could be
handled
and what happens
the kinds of models that that we had
in mind uh are all those where the
individual
agents have their independent dynamics
and within the population but you have
applications where
the dynamics of an individual agent may
be affected by an average of the states
of other agents so that's another
extension
and
and there are several several others
that one can
that we discuss in the in the paper so
i'll stop here thank you for your
attention
all right thanks a lot uh do we have any
questions
let's see
okay maybe i can start us off maybe
could you just quickly tell us a little
bit about what's known about kind of
mean field games when you go beyond the
like linear quadratic
setting oh there there is uh
in that case the uh the mean field
itself may not be it may not obey a
deterministic system so you have to deal
with
distributions yeah and so we do have
papers not not from the reinforcement
learning point of view but we do have
papers where for non-linear dynamics and
so on
where you you have as long as the
the coupling between the agents is
through that aggregate term
and and and that aggregate term
does not have to be replaced in the mean
field with the average necessarily but
with the distribution of that i see cool
uh let's see were there any other
questions about this uh talk
all right um i mean if there's no other
questions uh maybe we should uh let
everyone get to lunch
but uh we're gonna be resuming back at
uh two for the rest of the talks so
let's uh thank summer again